welcome to a special episode of BuzzFeed  unsolved supernatural in honor of the  new movie the curse of louder onna we're  doing something slightly different we'll  be looking for the titular antagonist  Lottie aronia to see if there's any  truth to the storied legend I tried to  roll those arse curls I know I heard you  like give up it's fine do you see La  Llorona  Leona now Shane the curse of La Llorona  is the story of a single mother fighting  to save her family from the evil Alya  Dona or weeping woman who wants to steal  her children and make them her own I'm  trying to figure out where this Falls  because it sounds part cryptid no Latin  country no matter who you talk to  everybody wants to claim it has their  own story this is kind of universal at  this point people see her and they're  like we know you just know this is where  she would prey on children tell me why  you did it why did you do that to your  children